[Music]
hello there and you're very welcome to
this special edition of the sky news
daily podcast with me dermot manahan as
we look back on some of the the big
stories of 2021 we've got a dozen of our
correspondents across three episodes as
we reflect back on those momentous
stories now over the next half an hour
we're going to be discussing these are
our themes in this podcast the royals
climate change and space and uh our
panel for this podcast let me introduce
you sky news his finest in the studio
with me are climate correspondent hannah
thomas peter we've got skies
who also i should say uh hosted a rival
podcast not a rival a sister podcast the
climate cast daily podcast during cop 26
and of course round and mills our royal
correspondent we're all in the studio
joining us remotely are our special
correspondent
alex crawford and our health
correspondent ashish joshi a lot as
always to get through so let's begin
with one of the big themes of the year
it is not a secret that cop 26 is a
failure collectively and individually
we are still falling short we have been
warned that this eruption could last
till december
this is the moment a part of the nanda
devi glacier broke flooding the dhali
ganga river and if we are to achieve our
goal to repair our planets in what is
now less than a decade
it is our shared responsibility
that's just some of it uh hannah you
better kick us off here because this was
the year 2021 when i was going to say
the alarm bells were ringing it's almost
more than that it's you know it's act
now or or doom the un this was the year
that the u.n said
that there was a code red for humanity
and that humans have been driving
climate change our world is warming and
that warming world is driving
increasingly frequent increasingly
severe weather events and goodness me
didn't we see those weather events
unfolding across the world not only in
the global south where climate change
has been biting for years now but
arguably this was the year that climate
change came to the doorstep of the
global north you had people freezing to
death in texas because the power grid
wasn't able to cope with electricity
demand you had people drowning in their
basements in new york city because the
infrastructure and drainage couldn't
cope with a severe storm we had
extraordinary heat waves and wildfires
in the pacific northwest and we had
devastating floods in western europe in
germany in belgium and of course those
wildfires in greece and turkey so it was
against that increasingly urgent
backdrop that 197 nations gathered at
cop 26 in glasgow and hannah did you
detect that sense of urgency amongst the
people gathering there absolutely
absolutely it was weighing heavily on
the shoulders particularly of the uk
which was the president
of the event tasked with herding cats as
one negotiator described it getting all
of those countries together in a room
and getting them to agree crucially on
some really tricky things that they all
disagreed on and the overarching aim of
the summit was to keep 1.5 degrees of
warming
alive or at least within sight and i've
had a couple of wash up conversations
post cop
and they all agree that 1.5
was kept within sight but only just i
think it's fair to say that they all
believe it's on life support so much
more to do alex uh well you were in the
south of the global north if i can mix
my geographical locations there in terms
of you know these these extreme
temperatures that that affected parts of
europe and those extraordinary fires
that we saw in in turkey we saw them in
greece as well oh my goodness they were
walls of it walls of it and this whole
sky went orange so first it went it was
raining ash so it's raining ash because
there was so many fires and there was so
much of it going on the air was very
foggy and smoggy and then in some cases
it just went utterly orange and the heat
was extraordinary because remember
um just in turkey say i mean it happened
in a range of european countries you
know from greece italy spain but just
say turkey where i was they broke their
60 year old record for temperatures and
these fires were
starting out of nowhere
pushed along by wind and the fire
services and the aircraft were
couldn't really cope with it it was
running so fast and the
the air was tinder dry the
forests were tinder dry so once a spark
was
washed you know blown along it caught
very quickly and we saw that ourselves
very very with it vividly because you'd
be in one part
and you'd drive along and we were wait
looking for a position to do a live a
live um update of what was happening and
just whilst we were waiting in the few
minutes
the the blaze came along look at that
sheet
of flames and the wind was blowing it so
that as i was standing there were small
hot patches and fires raging on my feet
and this was i think turkey that year
alone lost 160 000 hectares and that has
an impact not just on wildlife on
farmland people's homes were burnt to
the ground they were displaced we saw
tourists you know that was the thing
that really caught a lot of um
people's attention was tourists were
having to be evacuated on flotilla of
boats and and being rescued by by people
but but also it has an impact on
politicians and politics and that brings
me to ashish because you know you were
reporting
you know
some people said lucky you but um you
know it was the maldives but you know
just the
to be serious about it all just the
threat that they're facing from these
rising sea levels like you said i was
standing on these golden beaches palm
fringe turquoise waters it is in every
sense
paradise and that's why it's so
difficult to try and understand
what is happening to these
archipelago islands these coral reefs
that people
still want to go to for their holidays
and their honeymoons it's one of the
most desirable destinations in the world
but what is happening is it's facing an
existential threat on three levels
rising sea levels and these are recorded
by four to five centimeters every year
the sea levels are rising these are
low-lying islands in some places only a
meter above water they're being
submerged then you have coastal erosion
which is being driven by climate change
really
the monsoon seasons which was so
predictable i spoke to an old fisherman
who who's been going out on the indian
ocean for 50 years and he says before
when he was when he was a boy going out
to sea
his father could tell him
right for the next three months you're
not going to have any rain you're not
going to have any wind you're not going
to have any storms go out fish come back
he says it was that predictable but
nowadays he says you can't you can't
predict what's going to happen and then
you try and say to people well this is
an existential threat these islands
might not be here in 20 years half a
million people might have to be replaced
the moldivian government is already
thinking about that and the real damage
is also happening under the water these
coral reefs the rain forests of the
ocean they're dying they're being
bleached by rising temperatures if they
die they offer no protection to the
islands the entire marine ecosystem dies
with it and the tourists won't come so
it's a it's a triple whammy uh ashna i
want to bring in and i should give
the proviso here that we fully
understand it's uh nothing to do with
the human-led climate change but our
producers want to want to talk about it
the which you reported on the uh la
palma volcano which i suppose tells us
something does have an effect on the
climate and it tells us mother earth
itself is still playing a role i mean
the pictures are astonishing and i think
i said in one of my pieces going back a
few months that it would be over by now
this erupting volcano it started
erupting in september and here we are
months down the line that's still this
pouring out of lava walls of lava
columns of smoke still rising into the
into the atmosphere and it's quite the
site it's first time i've ever seen a
volcano um and you sort of go around and
everything is covered in volcanic ash
similar to what alex was describing in a
way i suppose and it's everywhere it's
in your hair it's it's what you're
breathing in as well you don't really
think about it you've got to walk around
with goggles and
for me though it's all the communities
that are
that have been lost they've been totally
consumed by the lava here and are still
not being able to get back to their
homes because there isn't a home to go
back to all of their belongings are gone
and they don't have jobs to go back to
either and rihanna before we get on to
the royals in detail in relation to
climate well of course her majesty the
queen was meant to be there but
unfortunately uh couldn't make it yes
she was but um with all due respect the
royals were literally all over cop 26
like a rash you could not move for them
having various bilats and meetings um
prince william described it as being
like speed dating and there was one day
where we were getting these constant
messages on the the royal whatsapp group
with all the raw correspondence where
they were saying right prince charles
has met macron he's met modi uh he's
meeting up with jeff bezos now and who
would have thought that prince charles
would be the one to kind of bring i
don't know in a date dating situation
together macron and jeff bezos when it
came to kind of bringing money to the
table it's a really important
issue for them we know that well right
back from prince philip he was really
crusading when it came to environmental
matters prince charles of course been
talking about it for the last 50 years
okay ryan and you're sticking around
because we're going to look back at some
of the other big stories involving
members of the royal family and uh
plenty of them but my thanks now to
hannah
ashner alex and ashish well three a's in
an h
thank you very much indeed
the duke and duchess of sussex harry and
megan will not be returning as working
members of the royal family my dear papa
was uh was a very special person after
the minute silence
a celebration for his royal highnesses
i'm very glad to have the chance to see
you if only mechanically this morning
her majesty carried out virtual
audiences from windsor castle her first
official engagement in seven days since
being ordered to rest by doctors how
much of a threat do you think these
proceedings are to prince andrew
well rhiannon i mean what a big year for
the royals it was i mean you know when
isn't there one but i mean in particular
with the the ending of an era the the
passing of prince philip and its effect
on her majesty the queen do you know
what derma i was thinking about that
that friday evening before the funeral
where
you and i and alistair bruce we we went
into the studio for the first time
and i think it was then that it that it
hit me that we had this
amazing window on this truly historic
event for the royal family and didn't we
have the most incredible position when
it came to i mean it does feel quite
intrusive as well yeah this is and
because of cobia it was a very small a
very private event and yes and this
above all is is a family grieving and i
think that was that was what was so
interesting about it and we talked about
it on the day both on and off air didn't
we that i think
this event this funeral had been decades
in the planning but because of covid
a lot of that had to be ripped up and so
yes we still had that amazing
military spectacle and it was the most
beautiful day at windsor
but also i think it was that kind of
intake of breath as we saw the coffin
being taken up the steps into st
george's chapel
and it was the silence wasn't it and
then into that very intimate choir space
and and it was simply just members of
the royal family dotted around and and
basically like so many other families up
and down the country just having to to
say farewell to
a much loved member of the royal family
in the most stripped back way
but also i think it allowed them to to
mourn in a way that they wouldn't have
been able to if if it hadn't been for
covet but you talk about the scene
inside the church and it was her majesty
yes the queen
sitting on her own
socially distanced with a mask on and we
were just imagining i suppose we didn't
need to imagine what was going through
her mind and we we talked about it
hadn't it hadn't we is she going to have
someone sitting alongside her of course
they were still having to to stick with
the the bubble rule just like everybody
else and in the end i think it was just
decided that no there wouldn't be a lady
in waiting with her she was simply going
to sit by herself but
but what an image an image of our time
an image i think of her reign
well let's talk about i mean you know
some of the troubles and their family
troubles on a plate in you know one of
them of course how shall i term it the
american branch of the of the royal
family the semi-detached branch
and uh that extraordinary interview with
oprah winfrey yeah it's not it has
really not been an easy year for the
queen has it and at 95 years old you
can't help but think
what are her family doing really um with
harry and megan yeah february
they announced they were having their
second child shortly after that it was
then announced right it's been a year
since they said they want to step away
they are now not going to be working
royals harry's military patronages were
taken away from him all that kind of
stuff we thought that was enough prince
philip was in hospital at the time and
then all of a sudden it was like no hang
on we're doing this interview with oprah
and then the week ticking up to that we
had this little drip of kind of teasers
of of what to expect
and i just thought wow okay they are
they are going to go there they are this
is not going to be subtle in any way
shape or form what was fascinating about
that interview was they kept going on
and on about the queen and how
supportive she'd been megan's saying oh
she shared her blanket in the back of
the car and this kind of thing
but ultimately
they were criticizing the queen she is
head of that institution and she's the
only one that could respond to those um
criticisms and in the end the statement
had to come from her ultimately she's
the ceo and i don't think any of us will
forget that recollections may vary line
um
exactly yes i i mean just to move on to
you know other continuing family
troubles and extraordinary interviews a
couple of years ago i'm talking of
course about uh the duke of york prince
andrew and uh you know his involvement
with jeffrey epstein and the the fact
that we see very very little of him now
he's apparently the queen's favorite son
so yeah two years now since he um
announced that he was stepping down from
from royal duties because of that
disastrous news night interview but this
year again it has completely blown up
because virginia dufrey who has made
these allegations against prince andrew
that she was sexually abused by him
uh of course allegations that he
strenuously denies she is now suing him
for compensation
and we have just had this endless twoing
and throwing
we've literally gone right into the
legal weeds if you like when it comes to
worse papers served in the right way
backwards and forwards it's like both
legal teams been playing chess in a way
but now we have got to the stage where
this hearing this this case is
proceeding and
so the last hearing that we had uh the
judge said look i could see us having a
trial between september and december in
2022. so this is just going to continue
to rumble on
during what should be next year
a nice year for the queen
her platinum jubilee
and yet you have issues with prince
andrew and the issues with harry and
megan we know that harry is due to
release a book at the end of next year
for example um all of that rumbling on
amongst all of the the jubilee build up
okay rhiannon many thanks sarah
corresponded round mills and well coming
up on the podcast we've got life in
space
and the metaverse no spacesuit required
for that well not yet anyway for this
next part of the podcast i'm joined by
our u.s correspondent greg milam
and sky's technology correspondent
roland manthop as we saw the space race
heat up in 2021
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back now for this part of the
podcast i'm joined by us correspondent
greg milam and technology correspondent
roland manthorp as we saw amongst other
things the space race hot up this year
ladies and gentlemen it's time to launch
this rocket godspeed new shepard i am
proud to announce that starting today
our company is now
well
and if life is found on mars it's the
great mythic cosmic quest
well uh we'll talk in uh detail more
detail about the space race itself in a
moment or two but of course some
crossover huge crossover into the area
of technology uh not least because of
some of the people who are involved
let's focus on on facebook one of the
biggest of them all and it's it's
rebranding to meta and going into their
metaverse and uh
i mean was that in part caused by some
of the extraordinary evidence we heard
on both sides of the atlantic from
a key whistleblower yeah i mean i don't
think you need to be a very cynical
person to think that this was partially
motivated by the desire to get rid of
the constant storm of bad news that was
brought up by the whistleblower francis
haugen i mean she was revealing
a mountain of evidence from deep inside
the company which showed that all the
things that people were saying on the
outside they were saying on the inside
too
but nothing was happening about them and
that is
really quite a severe charge
but at the same time this rebrand it
does
reach deep into the idealistic heart of
facebook because mark zuckerberg has
long long long been a believer in this
this possibility of this virtual reality
world the metaverse and it's that which
facebook and he thinks is going to be
the next big thing and this this name
change for the umbrella company of
facebook meta it it does signal a move
towards that and that he wants to own
that in the same way that his company
has really owned our mobile phones well
let's go from the metaverse to i suppose
the gateway to the universe see what i
did there greg and uh say there is cross
over here because of uh you know this uh
reinvigoration of the space race that we
saw involving these tech billionaires
amongst others uh elon musk and jeff
bezos you know just tell us a bit about
what's going on here i mean is it just
uh jaunts for the super rich or is there
something that that they're after that
they can monetize
i think that's the big question isn't it
um and they keep telling us this is
about more than just uh them going into
space and having a bit of a jolly with
their with their rich friends that
there's a uh a greater cause here but i
think if you said at the start of the
year that uh by the end of the year
richard branson would have been into
space jeff bezos would have been into
space allowing for that debate about
whether they actually did go into space
according to nasa they did um that
spacex would send passengers into orbit
for for multiple days i think
we'd have said back then this would have
been a pretty significant year for the
whole idea of of space tourism a real
landmark
year and i think crucially when you're
sending up the youngest person ever in
space the oldest person ever in space
the first paying passenger all of that
happening is is really significant and
what didn't happen is almost as
significant which is nothing went wrong
those also came out this year and i
almost forgot i'm sure you haven't
rather and this report on on ufos i'm
sure you've read it cover to cover it
does sound ridiculous on one hand but on
the other hand is that when you read
these accounts of these reports
completely
unexplained
incidents
it does make you wonder sometimes i i
don't like to go too far too far down
that road but
sometimes you you do have to think and i
think that is actually the position of
very serious people within the united
states government
they're not writing it in
but they're not writing it off either do
you know what guys after a year um
obsessing about ourselves almost naval
gazing it's uh great to end this series
of podcasts uh looking up and looking
beyond maybe not into the metaverse
though roland i'll leave that one to you
roland greg really good talking to you
thank you very much indeed now just to
remind you that all of these special sky
news daily podcasts there are three of
them with me dermot manahan are
available on demand uh wherever you
normally get your podcasts or videos
from
this edition was produced by annie joyce
along with felix forbes and kevin
donaldson thank you very much for
listening